- BUT YOU CAN'T SAY
THE NAME OF THE CELEBRITY
OR ANY PART OF THEIR NAME,
GOT IT?
- YEAH.
- YEAH, WE GOT IT.
- WE GOT IT.
- YOU ARE SO GONNA LOSE.
- BABY, YOU ARE GOING DOWN.
- WHY DON'T YOU START THE TIMER
AND BE AMAZED?
- AND...GO.
- OKAY, THIS GUY--
"E" EQUALS MC SQUARED.
- ALBERT EINSTEIN.
- YES, THAT IS CORRECT.
- WHAT?
EASY. HELLO?
- OKAY, THIS IS THE TERMINATOR.
- ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER!
- YEAH!
OKAY, WE GOT--WE GOT--
TALKING ABOUT, UH...
"ARE YOU TALKING TO ME?"
- ROBERT DE NIRO!
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH!
ALL RIGHT.
THIS PERSON PRETEND TO BE
STRAIGHT BUT HE'S REALLY GAY.
- ME!
[timer ticking]
- UH, UH--
HE IS, UH--[clears throat]
EXCUSE ME.
HE'S LIVING LA VIDA LOCA.
- ME.
- IT'S--
- NO.
- OKAY.
- HE'S A, UM...
LATIN POP STAR.
- I'M NOT A LATIN POP STAR.
- NO, YOU ARE NOT.
IT'S NOT YOU.
"HE BANGS, HE BANGS."
- OH, RICKY MARTIN.
- THAT IS CORRECT.
- I WROTE THAT ONE TOO.
[ding]